hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the TCC super final
season 15 it's a little latches 0 with
the white pieces again stockfish a lot
of you have requested this game and we
already mentioned in the previous game
that we've shown from this matchup that
if you enjoyed the Deaf one we're a
little played that line with the black
pieces maybe you would like to see the
one where she played with with the white
pieces so it's the exact same line but
the game is completely different so if
you haven't seen game 61 a really a
brilliant game Dalila one with the black
pieces do check it out it will be the
first link in the description below so
just to get into into the mood of this
wealth talk chess engine competition do
check that out before watching this game
so if you have done that congratulations
you are in excellent you know prepare
for the next game and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show well you
can also just watch the second one but
that being said Lila opens the game with
d4 so it's the exact same line as we're
stock which had white and Lila had Black
Knight of 6 with Bishop to g5 you
remember the nice from poverty line 94
attacking the best of the show back to a
four and now c5f three keeping the
knight back now we had this check of
course c3 blocks and now Knight goes
back to f6 with d5 and here Queen to b6
and now you remember that we already
mentioned the ponies under attack you
can defend with the Queen because you
also have to keep an eye on the d5 pawn
so butter up the c1 the same as in the
game where Lila had the black pieces and
here's where we deviate so the opening
has been pre-arranged up until this
point like every every two games is the
same and here these six was played by
Lila but here stocks which goes for a
different line stock which goes for a
six and it's now a completely different
game than the one we've had where Lila
had the black pieces we have efore by
Lila ECAP choice and v5e captor son d5
and only now d6 we have c-4 balilla
solidifying here in the center g6
preparing to fianchetto the dark square
Bishop and now comes Queen to e to check
by Lila and now you don't want to block
of course you can't block with the
Bishop due to the d5 pawn but if you
block with the Bishop e7 then Bishop to
h6 is
I'm very unpleasant you're not really
gonna castle you will still have to
waste a tempo unpinning this king and
it's just not a very nice position for
black so here after queen - e - we have
kink to d8 stockfish loses the castling
privilege but song has plans of casting
artificially later on in game as you'll
see so here there is one game in the
database where Queen to c2 was played
sir game obsession vs. Vasilis Petronius
in 2007 I revolt open but here a little
goes Queen back to d1 you have to make
room for your LightSquared Bishop to be
developed and it is now from moved world
that we have a completely new game
Bishop to g7 by stop 15 our Bishop to d3
and now Knight F to d7 this Knight is
not preparing to come to e5 to harass
the Bishop ended the c4 pawn front from
there we have Knights the e2 by Lola
nice to e5 s plant and now Knight b2 c3
like we mentioned you can't protect the
bishop is a Bishop c2 because you have
to keep an eye on the c4 pawn so just
night beat the c3 leave a continuous
development and the brush up to d7
we have castles by Lila and now Knight
to a6 here making room for the king and
c7 the rook can now come into the game
and then the King can go back to safety
and be ate with b3 preparing to
fianchetto the dark square Bishop also
putting more defense to the c4 pawn now
comes King to c7 as planned
a3 now with rook e8 e8 and Bishop back
to c2 now Allah is no longer interested
in allowing this tension to be in
sawfish favor with Bishop to c2 as now
we already said that the b3 porn defends
the c4 pawn and King to be 8 so you can
see that it took stock to show a while
but stock which was able to artificially
Castle even though it took him some 6
moves to castle but the king is not very
safe and now stock fish can go let's say
a 5 g 5g 4 and start the attack on the
King side with h3 by Leela and now f5
preparing g5 n g4 at some point with f4
by Leela pushing the knight back also
stopping g5 for the moment Knight back
to f7 and now rook the b1 here now
Leela is ready to push before and start
the attack on
Queen side we have rook H to g8 and now
not immediately before because then this
capture comes with check first you have
to deal with your king
so after this rook H to g8 by stockfish
King to H 1 first and now Queen to d8
stock tree doesn't want to the Queen on
the same file as Leila's rook will the
shop to be to grabbing more control of
the be for square and now Queen to e7
now this Knight can't really move
because you have to keep an eye on this
night and now push it back to d3 putting
more defense to this night here with
Knight back to d8 preparing B 6 and
after b6 this Knight wants to come to b7
and control the a5 square which will be
very important to after Leela start to
the attack on the Queen side and finally
before everything is you know all the
pieces are set perfectly and alia is not
ready to start the attack we have b6 as
planned and now although you want your B
file open for the rook capturing here
after Knight captures doesn't really do
all that much after Bishop to c2 and
night b7 you will have a very hard time
breaking this structure here and you
will not be able to continue your attack
successfully a four-night comes to a5
and it's just a better position for
black so after be six illegal goes b5
pushing pushes back the night and now
once the bust open the position with a
four and a five we have nice to see
seven and now not a four immediately
then again night to be someone would be
very strong first Queen to c2 butter up
to f6 now putting more pressure to the
g5 square and only now a four by Leela
night b7 a nice defensive move by
stockfish and now Knight back to c1 may
be preparing nice to be three and then
start pushing a5 the better from d2 will
also very nicely be controlling the a5
square and since this night will no
longer be any to this night can also
move with g5 stockfish na likes every I
heard the position of his pieces and
starts a the attack on the King side
with F captures and g5 Bishop captures
and g5 and now Knight back to e2 and
here it's important to eliminate the
dark square bishop as the dark square
bishop controls the a5 square
so the shrub capture some d2 we have
Queen captures and d2 and now nice to a5
preventing
any pawn pushing on the queenside and
now that a sawfish prevented Lila from
successfully attacking on the Queen side
now Lila transfers the plans to the
Kings side with rook to f3 h5 now and
now look beat f1 so nicely doubling
rooks and the F file and now h4 we have
rook want to F do all the everything is
nicely defended now in the rook eat f8
and Queen to h6 and here you have to
decide what to do
Ali lies putting pressure on this pawn
here ad there's also pressure on this
pawn here and you have to be very quick
to react to defend all of them first
nights the e8 putting more defense to
the d6 pawn and now comes Luke the III
the queen is now under attack and you
will not be able to defend anything
everything ok then I still is guarding
this point and you can click Queen dh2
keep an eye on this point here but then
you get nice to f4 this Knight is now
coming here it's gonna be very
unpleasant if R okay trade attacking the
Queen then night II 6 just the same if
rook captures Knight captures here the
trade will be in Leila's favor and if
Bishop captures then Queen captures on
e6 night g7 attacking Queen e7 and it
will be just a better position for Leela
so stalkerish finds a more active way to
treat this position not Queen to d7 but
rather Queen to f6 offering a trade of
Queens we have Queen captures on f6
Knight captures on f6 and now rook to f4
Lilla now puts pressure on the h4 pawn
and again if stock which goes with the
passive rook h8 then just king h2 this
rope is coming to d7 and it's just going
to be a super active position for
Leila's so after f4 a look at for stock
which goes for a temporary pawn
sacrifice with Bishop to c8
he frees the d7 square for Black Knight
the night is not coming to d7 and then
to e5 from where from a 5 both the a
five-night and the e5 Knight will go
after the c4 pawn so Lila grabs the pawn
with rook captures on h4 which is now
already very dangerous the th point is
now a passed pawn with a Knight to d7 as
planned and now Knight to f4 going for
the e6 square and now Knight to e5 so
for the moment
this pawn is now under attack you have
to react to this we have nice to eat six
attacking the rook and now both the
bishop and the rook are defending the
c-4 form so first look to f6 now
threatening to win the night and the
pawn after the phone is recaptured and
I'll just Bishop the back to f1 and not
allowing Knight captures and keeping an
eye on the g2 pawn we've looked back to
be eight and now comes Luke to g3 and
now finally Bushell character Sonny 6d
captures on e6 with rook F captures on
e6 and only now Knight to d5 so Black
Knight has the excellent FF score but
Allah now created an excellent d5 square
as an outpost which is a little bit more
important than this night being on e5
it's so far away from the King and there
is not much action going on there
whereas Lillis knight on d5 is very very
close to all the pawns there are you
know a lot of sneaky ideas here maybe
you can if you know everything is traded
off and the Kings are all on the Kings
side you know maybe you can just
sacrifice here push a5 and then after
black captures start pushing this pawn
it's just it's just better better as
there there's more going on there so
first we have looked to g6 stock which
offers a trader Brooks look back to c3
now defending this pawn the knight and
the district can now be activated as you
know no longer have to defend here you
can start activating with a roof to h7
we have looked to g7 and now comes look
to h6 going after this pawn here
rook the g6 blocking and now look back
to h4 and here look to f8 we have rooked
the f4 preventing this pawn from being
pushed and now rook back to f7 we have
Bishop to e2 hoping to win the exchange
with Bishop to h5 but now just rook to
g5 King to h2 Lilla improves the
position of the King and now Knight back
to g6 attacks Leo's rook rook to f2 and
now Knight back to e5 and here rook to
f1 by Leela look back to g8 or you could
try something like this to go after this
pawn but then g3 will just be very
strong the rook guards the g3 point and
you cannot start pushing your H pawn so
after looking one way
have looked back at the g8 and now comes
look to f4 rook jeet f8 doubling up on
the F file and now rook to g3 now again
this rook and this bishop are regarding
the c4 pawn so for the moment black has
no way of capturing it
we have rook to h8 and now comes King
back to g1 we have King to c8 a stock
which also now tries to bring the King
into the game but look the g5 and here
there are problems for black live and
managed to whittle in this rook to
attack the f5 pawn and you don't have a
good way of defending it if you play
something like rook h2 f8 to defend it
twice then Bishop to h5 is very strong
you force the rook away the knight is
controlling the f6 square so after you
move it then comes the bush of g6 just a
nice monster move where you will win the
DF 5 pawn after you capture it and of
course if Knight captures then it's just
a much much better position for white
your attacking this pawn and there's no
good way to defend it if you try and
defend it with the King then just Knight
f6 check will win the rook on h7 if you
try this then it's just a very passive
rook you're gonna go g4 and white will
just be winning here you can't capture
because the real captures on f8 and then
after black plays anything you'll play
either g5 or capture here and start
pushing your past pawns to victory
so after rook g5 we have night the b3 by
stockfish now trying to do something
this Knight no longer has a purpose
there you're trying to reintroduce it
into the game we have rook G captures on
f5 rook captures on f5 and now not
capturing here because then night here
attacks the rook and the bishop would be
a very unfortunate
rook f2 Knight captures un'ytu rook
captures and now look to h4 we'll just
be very strong for black as both the
knight and the rock are now attacking
the c4 pawn so after look at force on f5
knife to e7 check that was the idea
King to d7 and now just Knight captures
recaptures on f5 we have night the c1
attacking the bishop and now Bishop to
f1 just keeping an eye on the squares
that this Knight can use to get back
into the game rook F 2 and now G 4 so
now after all is said and done all you
guys up upon but more importantly
has two connected passports on the
kingside stock which has no points on
the kingside which is just very strong
night back to be three and now rook to
f2 we have nice - D - trying to get this
pawn on c4 of course if you capture the
knight of three check pics of the rook
so that's not possible we have the shot
- G - and now we have night D captures
on c4 capturing this c4 pawn here but
here leo has another monster move feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find it it's not a tactic or anything
it's just a very strong positional idea
which really owns it owns the board sort
of save so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this very nice move for
white I'll give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are just an
excellent finder of these super moves
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's Bishop to d5 and it's just a
just a beautiful idea a nice centralized
you move that prevents the black from
making any moves now you can't move this
night as you're gonna lose the night and
see for the night and c4 is not
protected of course after this Knight
moves and it's also one of the
principles you never want your Knights
to guard each other especially in a
position like this and the problem with
moving this night okay since this Knight
is guarded by the pawn there are no
immediate dangers there you don't have a
good square for it you can't go here you
can't go here you can't go here III is
guarded by the knight d2 and the b2 are
guarded by whites rook as you can see
here and you can go a three or a five
but you know good luck coming back into
the game after a three and what are you
going to do an a5 that this Knight
basically spent the entire game on a5
and you know it just made a few moves
trying to get back into the game and now
it's gonna go back to a5 not really not
really something so here you don't have
a good move here King to c7 stockfish
now has to wait and see what Leela does
look to a2 and now again there there's
no good move here if you just try and
repeat moves like say King the seven
white will just start bringing the King
into the game King gauge to play this
King III if you play it back h4 h5 King
can come all the way into the
and just simply went so stop which tries
at nights 285 it's ugly but it's a move
with King to h2 and now rook to e8 and
now comes g5 preparing to push this
point all the way and not only on d5 did
the bishop do all of those things but
also it guards the g8 square which is of
course is the queening square for the
Jeep on route back to f8 now comes
Knights the H for getting the knight out
of harm's way
rogue back to d8 now preparing rook to
d7 to control the g7 square g6 rook to
d7 guarding the g7 square and now rook
the g2 preparing to push it all the way
here we have looked to g7 blocking the
pawn but now as well once you have to
use the rook to block the pawn and
you're down upon it's not a great
position to be in so now most likely all
of you would be expecting yes the rope
is now here we have a knight here one
after Knight to f5 we just push it away
and well for the moment it doesn't work
because both the rook and the night are
at sorry both the rook and the night are
attacking the g6 bond but here again
we'll adjust finds a brilliant move and
feel free to pause the video again and
try to find it I'll give you a couple of
seconds it's even nicer than the
previous one for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent King marcher and for those of
you who just want to enjoy it show the
movies actually came to g3 and I know
what you're thinking but what about the
g6 pawn well if rook captures then
Knight captures rook of course and of
course even Knight captures then King
back to h2 and now you lose them here
you lose the piece here either rook will
capture or you will have to play
something capture the night and then
just a rook captures and g7 with Czech
and it's all over
so a brilliant move by Lee lat King to
g3 and now you can see that you cannot
prevent this March
King is coming to f6 and is a game over
we have c4 stocker starts pushing the
past pawn but now King to f4 with Knight
to b3 and now just keep the g5 we have
nice to see five and now kink to h6
attacking the rook and now you can't
move the rook if you move the rook well
you can go here Bishop guards there if
you just move added into the pawn
continuous marching forward so we have
Knight captured
six and now although you can capture
with the rook but it would
it is winning but it would take Lila
somewhat longer to win this game after
c3 you would have to go tonight at for
c2 night e to block the C 1 square
Knight captures an a4 and of course it
is winning but it would take some time
so we will just play Knight captures on
g6 this rook is now coming to pick up
the past point so no surprises there we
have looked back to d7 and now comes
rook to c2 we have looked the d8 now
comes sorry not G 7 look to d8 and now
comes route captures on c4 rook to e8
and now h4 we have rook to e3 now comes
h5 rope the d3 attacking the bishop and
here as it is in these engine games when
both alia and stockfish decide that the
evaluation goes over some point that
there is no point in continuing it is
basically in this point that stockfish
resigned the game or they both agreed
the stoppage was losing and then the
game was over and a lot of you have a
not a lot of you but some of you have
said that I should have mentioned in the
previous game game 61 between stockfish
and Lila were Lila had the black pieces
that it was a very interesting how Lila
Lila's evaluation was showing the Lila
was winning but at the same time
stalkerish evaluation was showing that
it was pretty much a drone game so
that's why the game lasted as much as it
did and you know it took stockfish a
while to realize that that stock which
was losing but here i don't know the
what was the evaluation during the game
for Lila and for structures but if any
of you do know do share and I will of
course give you a heart or pin your
comment so everyone else can enjoy these
nice facts as well so not only did Lila
win game 61 in game 62 which is huge
winning the same line with the white
pieces and the black pieces so it means
that it's not a problem with the line
Lila is just the the you know the
superior chess entity and not only that
Lila won the entire super final so last
season in season 14 stockers won the
super final Lila won the tournament and
then after Lila started the match with
the superior version of stockfish from
100 games the result was I believe 50
and a half
forty nine and a half so starfish one by
one point margin but here in season 15
after a hundred games a leela 153 and a
half at the forty six and a half which
is just insane you know
defeating starfish like that it's well i
think it's just something that we were
gonna have to get used to ever since
ever since alpha zero versus stalkerish
we've learned that self learning neural
networks are probably the future of
chess and not your standard engines like
stock fish and I don't know if Leela
will participate in the next season of
the talk chess engine competitions now
it's pretty obvious that she will win
and both the the championship and the
super final but I hope I hope that they
continue and to see how how strong she
can get and maybe who knows if if the
good people in deepmind will you know
maybe like this maybe maybe we'll even
have a nice short match at least let's
let's say ten games between Leah and
alpha alpha would probably win all the
games but it would still be super
enjoyable to watch and try to make sense
of the moves but yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it like I said if
you haven't seen it do check out the
previous game game 61 also very
enjoyable I would like to thank Trevor
there - Dan and Jay Brad Brad ROG and
Nicholas paddle for a contribution to my
channel I think a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos your thing called for
watching and I will see you soon with
some more hopefully interesting content
we have well the Grand Prix finals to
check out and while we're waiting for
the noir Norway OtterBox championship
were gonna be continuing the Capablanca
saga thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day